I'm Sterling Tadlock. And I grew up in eastern North Carolina. in a really small
rural community. about 50 minutes southeast of Raleigh.
In a little town called Grantham. I was
raised as an only child. My dad was a Sheriff's Deputy. My mom was a stay at
home mom. we lived a pretty country, a rural life. you know, we never
really traveled outside of the state. and I grew up as an only child thinking
my parents were my real parents. which I
still classify them as my real parents. But
yeah I didn't really any thing, think anything about it until I got a little
bit older. And sort of realized that, you
know, I don't really look like my parents
>> How old were you when that, when that happened?
>> I
was probably, you know, probably 11, 12 when I sort
of noticed. You know, my parents have different body shapes than
me. I always just, sort of wondered, why is that? And,
sort of just put it to the back of my mind.
>> Mm hm
>> although I did notice that my friends, parents and
their siblings looked more similar than I looked to my parents.
>> Mm hm
>> But again, I didn't really question in
it because I didn't really think anything of it.
That was really the only exposure I really had,
I never really understood, you know, growing up what
adopted meant. Just because sex is not talked
about in eastern North Carolina and the understanding of
where you come from. through your biological parents wasn't
really ever brought, so the concept of being adopted
was also never brought up.
>> So how old were you when you finally actually sort
of, figured it out? Or someone talked to you about it?
>> So, it was a really interesting story. I was 14. And
like most people in eastern North Carolina was raised in the Church. The
Church was a big facet of everyone's life. And I
went to Sunday School one day. I was 14 and coincidentally it was Father's Day
>>
[LAUGH]
>> And in church that day, in Sunday school lesson the teacher was talking
about how whenever you become adopted. Or whenever you become a Christian, you
become adopted into God's family. And he then looked
at me and he said So, why don't you tell the class what it feels like
to be adopted, Sterling. And, that sort of struck me.
Because I, I had never heard that I
was adopted before. Like I said, I thought that...
>> Mm hm.
>> You know? I look a little bit different
than my parents. And but then I saw pictures
of me as a baby with my parents. And so. You know, I just thought about it and I
was like no, I can't be adopted. And I
remember there was a lil, a girl, a distant
cousin of mine who said Sterling's not adopted those
are his real parents. and so, I sort of squashed
it in church although there was this rumbling anxiety within me.
>> Mm-hm.
>> and then I went to the sermon portion of church and I sat between
my grandmother, whom I refer to as me-maw, And my mama on the other side. And
[COUGH]
I leaned over to my memaw and I was
like, so am I adopted? And she didn't look at
me, she looked, kept looking straight at the pulpit. And
she's like, you're going to have to ask your mother about
that. and so then I turned to my mama
and I was like, so I heard in Sunday school
that I'm adopted. And she's like, well you are. And
I just kind of froze, right there in the pew, and
[COUGH]
I just was in shock. I, I didn't really react at first, and then I just started
tearing up and crying and stood up and just sort of left.
I think it's one of the sort of disadvantages in a way of being adopted is
this notion of survivor's guilt where there's a big disaster.
this is where the term came form originally, I believe.
There's a big disaster and those that survive the disaster
feel guilty because they are not the ones that have been
injured or killed... And, when you're adopted, you feel like,
I was chosen, you know, by my parents. But there are
plenty of other people still in the foster care system
who weren't adopted. And you feel like you should be grateful,
you know, that you were adopted. And you should be
thankful every day that you live that you have a
family that you know, raised you and supported you. And,
and I am thankful, but you know, anytime I question
being adopted, who my biological parents are, that's like a twinge of guilt.
>> How did that make you think
about your biological parents? Once you discovered this
information, what was going through your mind
about the scenario in which you found yourself?
>> Right.
>> Did you have a lot of questions?
>> Yeah, I mean, I think there's a lot of fantasy that goes on with,
you know, who they could be. Like, are they like me? Do they act like me?
Do they talk like me? What are their
professions? Like, what if it's like, you know.
I remember when I was a teenager, like
what if it's like some European like. royal family.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Who like, ships their child off to North Carolina.
And was reared by you know, some really awesome Southern parents.
>> Mm-hm.
>> that obviously came to mind. Also like, what if they're in jail?
>> Or you know, you know, not even alive. Like,
even that, that came into mind. So I was just
always curious as to what they were. What they were
like. and also what was the situation that led them
to having to put up a child for adoption? I'm also
just sort of curious about their lives. Like, what are they like?
if I have any siblings or not. I mean that's always
a question of mine. if there are any health considerations? You know,
there are a lot of health diseases medical diseases. Have the
huge genetic component and like knowing that information is important to me.
>> You know, as part of participation we've offered you an
opportunity to actually submit a DNA sample and find out. You know,
if there in the 23andMe program if you might
find any genetic relatives of yours. you know, what
are your thoughts surrounding that. You, you've submitted your,
your, your DNA. You submitted your sample, but you haven't
seen your results yet. you know, what are some
thoughts going into that about participating in a program like
that. And what you expect to see, what you
expect to find and how that might make you feel.
>> You
know, to be honest, I haven't thought about
it too much, because Again, that fantasy play
of, you know, finding my biological parents. Like,
finding the DNA that may match with mine and
seeing what percentage the similarities are and being
able to contact them. I don't want to disappoint
myself, because I know that the the highest
likelihood is that there's probably going to be some distant,
distant cousin that has similar DNA to, to me. So I'm not really putting a
whole lot of stock into it, as far as finding somebody. But I am interested in
seeing you know, the other facets of my DNA. That 23andMe will sort
of elucidate such as risk for medical diseases. And
pharmacological sort of ability to metabolize drugs and respond
to them. I think that's a part of it, and just generic ancestor stuff.
>> Are you excited to see your 23andme results?
>> I am, I am, I've been holding out. They've
actually been available for a little bit now, but For the
purposes of the interview, I've sort of held back. I'm waiting
on the edge of my seat to see what they say.